hello everyone I'm judge Janine Piro
along with Jessica tarlo Jesse Waters
Martha mallum and Greg Gutfeld it's 5:00
in New York City and this is the
[Music]
five liberal leaders are finally
cleaning up San Francisco but it's not
because they want to fix the crime and
drug filled City for residents it's all
to impress world leaders and top CEOs
coming to town for a big economic Summit
next week the Democratic city has
refused to lift a finger to address
drugs homelessness and crime but now
that Joe Biden and president G are
coming to town next week the roads will
be repaved the streets power washed to
get rid of all the graffiti and the
public transportation stations will have
added overnight deep cleaning it's so
obvious what is going on that even
liberal California governor Gavin
Newsome admits they are putting a
Band-Aid on a bullet wound I know folks
say oh they're just cleaning up this
place cuz all those fancy leaders are
coming into town um that's
true because it's
true but it's also true for months and
months and months prior to Apec we've
been having different
conversations and we've raised the bar
of expectation folks are saying this is
not what I thought it was going to be
based on what was what's been in the
media because I think what happens
sometimes is a moment a snapshot is
taken and it's not always San Francisco
it's sometimes the Bay Area it's some
place in some other city and it's
attributed to San Francisco so I think
we've gotten a lot of unfair
press and over on the east coast if you
try to stand up for victims of crime you
may be labeled a criminal yourself one
vigilante opening fire in a subway
station in an attempt to scare away a
wouldbe robber threatening to steal a
woman's purse he is now being charged
with criminal possession of a firearm
and reckless endangerment and is out on
$10,000 bail okay so Jessica explain why
it's more important to clean up the
cities and roll out the red carpet for
leaders like xiin Ping than for ordinary
American taxpayers and do you buy that
uh Gavin newams we've been working on
this for months and months and months as
an excuse for not having done it earlier
well it's not just cheing President
Biden's coming kamla is coming it's a
whole Summit and this happens everywhere
right I mean when you have someone come
over you clean up right in our homes and
you remove all the drug dealers from
your front porch I tell Brian you pick
up that poop right now this is
unacceptable um so that part of it
obviously doesn't surprise me I do think
you know we've heard from London breed
and the uh the new DA after Chessa
Boudin got thrown out that the Way San
Francisco is is not acceptable that they
will be they will lose their first tier
City status from this and that it's just
devastating when you walk around and you
see what's going on with the
homelessness and the drug addic
addiction um so yeah I I do believe him
about that and I hope that this becomes
a catalyst for fast-moving change that
they say oh this was so much nicer what
can we do to make sure that this is
something that we can maintain in the
future you know Martha one of the things
that um the Chinese apparently know from
their own version of Tik Tock as well as
from the media coverage that they are
doing in China is they say that San
Francisco looks like and has been
branded a quote Ru City hell a total
failure so the effort to bring in this
this pacif Pacifico and China whatever
this economic Forum uh do you think
it'll last that businesses will invest
um well it's a great Point uh the first
thing that comes to mind when you bring
up China is that they understand this
kind of cleanup really well they did it
before the Beijing Olympics if you
remember they basically moved the slum
areas they moved it so that like
everybody's traffic would not see a lot
of what exists in their country so this
is a process that Xi Jinping is very
familiar with um how to sort of kind of
you know whitewash the city and make
things perfect for the people who are
visiting so that they don't actually see
the way people live there so that is
that that's one thing the other thing is
that I think Gavin is cleaning up uh for
his election as well I mean this you
know President Biden's coming he has to
do a cleanup job and he doesn't want you
know the rest of the country whose eyes
may be on this Apex Summit for a bit um
to see the way that people are living in
that City and I'm I'm reminded also when
you talk about economic incentives of
the days when New York had a huge
turnaround right I mean you had juliani
who did an excellent job and you had
Bloomberg who also did an excellent job
of policing tax policy policy
encouraging businesses to move to New
York lowering regulations encouraging
the police officers backing law
enforcement giving them a recognition at
you know at every step of the way and
you could see it I mean you just watched
it turn around in New York city so so
they can do that it it it's really not
as complicated as I think it might sound
they cleaned up people off the streets
they helped people to get into hospitals
and rehab centers which Eric Adams has
said he wants to do I think he got s by
a number of things but that's something
that he said he wanted to do so um I
think it's clean up for the 2024
election cuz we know that he's hoping
that things will shift and he'll be able
to run all right Jesse you know um
speaking of crime and and what happened
with Giuliani and followed up by
Bloomberg I mean this week we saw a New
York City guy uh who had a job who was
arrested for criminal possession of a
weapon reckless endangerment for trying
to help a woman who is being victimized
to say the very least by someone who was
mentally ill at a subway station who was
trying to rob her now what I find most
interesting about it Jesse is that the
guy who shot off a warning shot um had a
college degree he's had one job for 17
years he had tost $10,000 Bond the
mentally ill guy who attempted to Rob
and has been arrested and is homeless
has no bail how fair is that no it's
like we're living in an age where you
are throw real men in prison and you are
letting weak Predators get out on bail
and I'm not saying this guy shouldn't
have you know done what he did I don't
know if you should be licking warning
shots off on the subway I maybe I would
have put the gun up like this and aimed
it at the guy and say scram vagrant
maybe that could have done the job but
the point is this you are criminalizing
masculinity there is a masculine
instinct to protect women who are in a
vulnerable position and if you continue
to do that year after year what you're
going to do is you're going to destroy
honor in New York and if
you destroy the police and if you
destroy manhood you're going to see an
era of predators where predators are
going to run wild and all the women and
all the Liberals are going to say hey
hey wait a second what well this is the
result of what we've been doing over the
last several years and
in terms of Gavin
Nome the reason you clean up for people
when they come over is because you want
to show them
respect and if you yourself live in
filth then you don't respect yourself so
if I was a taxpayer in San Francisco
they're using my money to show respect
to the Chinese and not clean up for me
that means the politicians in San
Francisco do not respect the taxpayers
and Jessica they have big Summits in
Chicago New York Houston it's not a
story when they clean up for people
because they don't have to clean up so
much San Francisco has L it Fester to
the point we're cleaning up this
much you don't see that kind of stuff in
Chicago like that in terms of quality of
life there's crime there's not people
with needles sticking out of their arm
as kindergarteners Walk shooting
5-year-olds through Windows yeah there's
crime there's crime but it's talking
about quality of life we're treding to
send a camera to the tender la tonight
to do a story and we wouldn't even have
the camera man go there he refused to go
it's too dirty too dangerous all right
great you fired him which I thought and
now he's fired yes Greg you could talk
about crime you could talk about XI
jingping I think you know China gets the
red carpet the residents get the brown
carpet and it can't and they said they
they needed to get on the ball because
they were having company it's not like
having company this is more like having
child care services show up so hide the
drugs put the bruised kids in the back
room this is not about impressing it's
about hiding I mean they're trying to
impress China why don't you take care of
the Asians in your city first there's no
shortage of high-profile anti-asian
crime in San Francisco in 2022 alone
there was something like
567 per increase in reported Asian hate
crimes and those are what was reported
not actual but reported but here's the
big point which Martha you made uh
America never used to do this they never
had to do this you could come to the
city and it would be great you didn't
have to throw a Fresh coat of paint on
squalor that was the practice of
communist hell holes we called them pkin
Villages Jesse use that tonight PM that
where you construct a facade right to
trick people into believing a city that
is a dump really isn't a dump so whether
you know when one of our presidents went
to China or USSR they just sweep up the
poor they'd uh they they' paint over the
decaying eyes Source fix up the
buildings and for a few days the city
would Sparkle So we keep we've always
been saying like what happens to these
cities when liberals take over they get
do they get their communist Utopia they
did they did it's a turd with a coat of
paint they got exactly what they wanted
as for uh as for what happened in New
York City we predict did this that when
you handcuff the police and you release
deranged criminals what can a citizen do
and D McDow made this point that
self-defense becomes self-help but if
you have a Le I think I thought his
weapon was legally owned from 1 years it
was legally owned it was and someone's
in distress and this is to Jesse's point
you might feel compelled to help right
but in this city the way it is now would
you I mean look what happened to Daniel
peny if you step up you get screwed and
that is and that is changes the way a
man thinks and Jesse
Yeah okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else